elecciones y un polémico referendo cerca
de 13 millones de Ecuatorianos elegirán
5.660 autoridades locales las campañas
culminaron el 2 de febrero el
oficialismo trató de desmarcarse el
presidente Guillermo lasso quien ha
visto su popularidad afectada por
escándalos recientes de corrupción en su
familia el debate no se centró en los
candidatos sino en ocho reformas
constitucionales que lazos somete a
referendo y que la oposición ha señalado
que representan un riesgo para la
democracia la reforma constitucional
Busca reducir el número de asambleístas
controlar el número de afiliados a los
movimientos políticos a través del
Consejo Nacional electoral y aumentar la
autonomía de la fiscalía general la
designación del fiscal pasaría a manos
de la asamblea nacional esta también
seleccionaría a los miembros del Consejo
de participación ciudadana organismo de
control creado en 2008 que elige al
procurador general otra enmienda Busca
la extradición de hayan cometido delitos
relacionados con el crimen organizado
transnacional como el narcotráfico
tráfico de armas y la trata de personas
desde la oposición la confederación de
nacionalidades indígenas compuesta por
14 pueblos originarios anunció que no
apoyara ninguna reforma el 18 de
noviembre la conaie decidió trabajar en
la consulta popular todo por el no el
gobierno se mantiene firme y defiende
como uno de los ejes de sus propuestas
la lucha contra el crimen organizado
creo que además manda un mensaje
comunicacional importante y que los
Ecuatorianos estamos dispuestos a
decirle sí a un ecuador más seguro menos
politiquería y también más cuidadoso con
el medio ambiente los Ecuatorianos
también votarán sobre la creación de un
subsistema de protección
hídrica al Sistema Nacional de áreas
protegidas y compensaciones para los
ciudadanos que cuiden el ambiente